Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
director Mick Mulvaney made headlines
this week with his blunt confirmation of
what we all suspected was true in the DC
swamp talking about his time in Congress
he said if you're a lobbyist who never
gave us money I didn't talk to you if
you're a lobbyist who gave us money I
might talk to you since then an
investigation by The Daily Beast has
revealed that norvania is still at it
even with his powerful new job in the
White House at least eight registered
lobbyists and six other executives who
donated to his congressional campaigns
or whose company's political action
committees donated to him got a meeting
with Mulvaney after he became budget
director now of course that's outrageous
it totally undermines the president's
drained the swamp agenda and it needs to
stop unsurprisingly many people got on
the Mick Mulvaney bashing bandwagon this
week among them was Democratic senator
from Pennsylvania Bob Casey he tweeted
this is supposed to be a government by
the people for the people not a
government of the thieves and money
changers Mick Mulvaney is a disgrace hmm
interesting I kind of agree and
obviously Senator Bob Casey would never
issue such a thundering denunciation of
Mick Mulvaney --zz lobbyists ties if he
himself took money from lobbyists would
he I mean that would be so shamelessly
hypocritical is too much even for the
swamp but we just thought we'd check you
know to be safe Senator Bob Casey as
this week's swamp Watch
[Music]
as we just showed you senator Casey
raged against Mick Mulvaney over
donations from lobbyists we'll get to
that in a moment but here's a little
appetizer for you the first thing you
noticed when looking for Bob Casey's
ties to the swamp is the way his
staffers spin round Washington's corrupt
revolving door nathan steinwald was a
legislative assistant for casey from
2007 to 2009 before joining stern he'll
group as a lobbyist in 2013 Stern held
group has bought in more than eight
million dollars in lobbying contracts
since time all joined including for
finance and health care or
pharmaceutical companies that's handy
given Bob Casey's membership of the
Senate Finance Committee and the Senate
health education labor and pensions
committee another Casey staffer named
Jared Solomon served as vice president
of budget policy at an advocacy group
called first focus from 2011 to 2014
Solomon left that job to work as a
legislative assistant for Senator Casey
for four years and then he left senator
Casey to become a lobbyist for Bo's
public affairs group his clients have
included the American Indian higher
education consortium and the Coalition
of higher education assistance
organizations of course he lobbied for
education interests his former boss
serves on the Senate committee that
oversees education policy that's how it
all works in the swamp and then there's
Casey Jillette a former Casey staffer
who's been through the revolving door so
many times I don't know how she's not
dizzy she started as a staffer for
Senator Bob Graham in 2000 before
leaving to become the assistant director
of government relations at the National
Audubon Society in 2004 the next year
she went back to Washington working for
senators debbie Stabenow Bob Casey and
Harry Reid in Harry Reid's office she
worked as his policy advisor for
agriculture so of course she left that
job to become a lobbyist for Monsanto
don't you love the way Bob Casey attacks
Mulvaney over lobbying when so many of
his own staffers are cashing in on their
experience in his office to peddle
influence on K Street but hang on a
second you might say those are just his
staffers senator Casey himself isn't
part of the swamp he's obviously clean
as a whistle otherwise he'd never have
called Mick Mulvaney a disgrace would he
would he take a look at
this chart it shows the business sectors
that have donated to Senator Casey's
campaign since 2013 two of the sector's
with the highest donations are
industries he specifically regulates as
part of his committee assignments
including 1.5 eight million from the
finance insurance and real estate sector
and 1.2 two million from the health
sector but you may say that's just what
goes on in Congress we know it's all
basically corrupt senator Casey was
incensed about something much more
specific donations from lobbyists
there's no way he'd go on the warpath
about donations from lobbyists if he
actually did the same thing would he oh
look according to the Center for
Responsive Politics on April the 25th
2017
senator Casey took a two thousand seven
hundred dollar donation from Ben Barnes
a lobbyist on June the 14th 2017 he took
a two thousand five hundred donation
from David Caston yet another lobbyist
and on March 2 20th 2017 he took five
hundred dollars from the Podesta group
no need to tell you what they did for a
living
Casey took money from Alpine Group a
lobbying firm whose clients include
pharmaceutical giant Amgen and health
care giant Centene corporation both
directly affected by the Senate Health
Committee which Casey serves on he took
money from capital tax Partners a
lobbying firm whose clients include the
National Council of farmer coops who
just might be interested in the fact
that Senator Casey serves on the
agriculture nutrition and forestry
committee
he also took money from Capitol Council
which lobbies for Amalgamated Bank Bob
Casey is on the Senate Finance Committee
all told sanctimonious holier-than-thou
Senator Casey took 198 donations from
136 lobbyists just in the 2018 election
cycle here are their names
scrolling on the screen this giant
hypocrite so he gets a jump down Mick
Mulvaney 's throat for taking money from
lobbyists himself took one hundred and
seventy seven thousand dollars from
lobbyists in the 2018 election cycle
eighty two thousand dollars from
lobbyists in the 2016 cycle and two
hundred and ninety
thousand dollars from lobbyists in the
2012 cycle it all adds up to a grand
total of more than six hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars from
lobbyists in his Senate career
who knows what favors he did in exchange
for all that cash well we want to find
out and so we'll be submitting a Freedom
of Information request to see who he and
his staff have met with and what was
discussed we invited senator Casey to
come on the show and answer to you for
all this but he turned down our offer
and instead gave us this statement Mick
Mulvaney admitted to selling access to
him in his office in exchange for
donations while Senator Casey is working
to pass the reforms that will get money
out of politics the difference could not
be clearer notice that he doesn't deny
selling access to him and his office
Senator Casey you are the disgrace you
preach about getting money out of
politics while pocketing hundreds of
thousands of dollars from lobbyists and
millions of dollars from industries that
you regulate you make me sick and the
sooner you're kicked out the better